bonjour à tous je suis c'est quoi ils
l'attaquent tech savez vous ce qu'est le
produit intérieur brut je vous explique
aujourd'hui de quoi il s'agit alors
c'est quoi le produit intérieur brut le
produit intérieur brut aussi appelée pib
est apparu le 4 janvier 1934 il s'agit
du premier outil macro économiques
pouvant mesurer la richesse d'un pays
grâce au pib on peut quantifier la
croissance économique mais aussi à
l'envers ce la récession économique le
pib permet donc de surveiller la santé
leur pays et c'est quoi la différence
avec le pmb le pnb est le produit
national brut il calcule le montant des
richesses créées par les acteurs
économiques de même nationalité mais qui
ne sont pas forcément dans le pays le
pib quant à lui évalué le monde on a la
richesse créée par les différentes
activités économiques d'un pays c'est là
peut-être des services haut débit ans
mais peu importe la nationalité des
producteurs c'est une donnée prise
généralement sur une année où sur un
trimestre et concrètement comment est
calculé le produit intérieur brut pour
comprendre comment est calculé le pib
prenons l'exemple d'une boulangerie pour
faire du pot le boulanger a besoin de
farine d'eau et d'électricité on appelle
cela des consommations intermédiaires
pour calculer la richesse créée du
boulanger aussi appelé la valeur ajoutée
il suffit de soustraire au prix final du
pain la consommation intermédiaire du
boulanger c'est à dire la farine l'eau
et l'électricité pour obtenir le pays et
en france il suffit de faire la somme
des richesses de tous les producteurs
sur le territoire santé et qui calcule
le pib et l'insee qui calcule le pib
près de 80 personnes chaque année vont
recenser l'activité économique du pays
quelles sont les limites du pib une
augmentation du pib signifie qu'un pays
connaît une croissance économique et à
linverse une diminution du pib traduit
une récession économique cependant le
pib a tout de même ses limites car ils
s'appuient sur les prix qui évoluent
constamment qu'ils peuvent monter sous
l'inflation et baissé sous la déflation
ce qui peut fausser le résultat du
calcul du pib par exemple si le blé
augmente le prix du pain du boulanger
augmentera également car le boulanger
voudra avoir les mêmes marges ce qui a
fortiori fera augmenter le pib mais pas
la richesse du pays
j'espère que vous avez bien compris ce
qu'est le produit intérieur brut à
bientôt pour un nouvel épisode